Google cloud max 2017 hosted a plethora
of talks detailing the future of cloud
if you didn't get a chance to catch the
session connected retail and devices and
stay tuned because here's the recap as
technology improves in the public sector
it's straightforward to expect that
it'll influence the commercial sector as
well in fact it's already predicted that
by 2020 72 percent of US workforce will
work from a mobile location which brings
up big questions about how we create the
right technology and ecosystems to
support connected workspaces and
connected store fronts in the future now
there's two sides to this coin first is
how you instrument analyze and improve
the connectivity and data flow of your
internal workers on the other side the
storefront of the future has to find a
way to combine the benefits of the
physical retail space and the benefits
of the connected digital space without
making it more difficult for customers
or employees for example with a mobile
enabled staff updates and information
can be pushed out to employees on the
show floor meanwhile they can update the
name stocking databases in real time or
if signage is more of your style
replacing physical signs with digital
ones have seen a lowering and cost and
allowing more variability and control
over time on the cutting edge of things
is virtual reality and augmented reality
which could help customers get a better
sense of what the products would look
like in their own homes and your store
managers get a more immersive experience
and what installations would look like
inside your retail spaces and of course
let's not forget those metrics a newly
connected retail means the ability to
detect when users are near product
triggering local changes and giving
feedback to you on what product is being
engaged now in this talk a very special
partner takes the stage to show how
they've utilized all these technologies
to create a strong interactive and
next-generation display system for their
retail operations but you should really
go watch the full video of that we're
not going to be able to do that
presentation justice here so if you want
to see more recaps on great next content
make sure to check out the rest of our
playlist and don't forget the next world
tour
coming soon to a city near you
[Music]
you
[Music]